on va parler maintenant des produits bio
si vous le voulez bien puisque dans
révélations sur rmc story on s'est
intéressé aux articles vendus dans les
magasins bio et ben figurez vous que
dans certains d'entre eux ne mériterait
pas défigurer regarder la grande
nouveauté des magasins bio depuis une
quinzaine d'années c'est que vous pouvez
rentrer dans un magasin bio et retrouvé
une bonne partie des produits que vous
trouvez en alimentation conventionnelle
c'est à dire que vous allez avoir et
pizzas l'aider préparation des plats
cuisinés
ici on trouve entre 3500 et 4000
références et en y regardant de plus
près tout n'est pas absolument bio une
autre catégorie de produit existe des
plats partiellement bio ce poisson pané
a été pêché donc effectivement il n'a
pas été élevé selon les règles de la bio
en revanche la panure qui est qui est
dessus est composé exclusivement
d'ingrédients biologiques alors un
poisson pané qui n'a de piau que la
panure est ce une façon d'induire le
consommateur en erreur le producteur
cherche t-il seulement à bénéficier de
la bonne publicité du label alors en
2016 les consommateurs de l'hexagone en
dépenser 7 milliards d'euros pour
acheter des aliments bio soit plus de 20
% sur un an
est ce que justement ne profite pas de
cette niche de cette nouvelle niche
cette manne des consommateurs et
peut-être parfois en les amusant comme
là il semblerait quand même que bon le
poisson n'est pas bio en revanche n'ya
pas nouvelle et elle mais moi je
constate titre personnel que voilà le
bio en fait c'est une façon de donner
aux consommateurs une bonne conscience
et une façon aussi aux industriels de
gonfler les prix pourquoi parce que le
bio on a le sentiment grâce à son label
vert assez joli on a l'impression que
finalement c'est inoffensif pour notre
santé alors que pas du tout on peut
avoir un produit bio qui a été élevé
dans des pesticides ya 106 produits
phytosanitaires qui sont autorisés pour
les relais que le vieil a pas de
pesticides a manqué de rien vous pouvez
en avoir il ya aussi ici où ils ont
découvert dans certaines études qu'il y
avait effectivement des produits qui
étaient très dangereux notamment aussi
pour la biodiversité
donc le bio c'est pas si inoffensifs que
ça donc faut vraiment qu'on arrête avec
défenderesse des
riz bio bien se faire grimer et damien
qui participent à ce complot j'ai
l'impression qu'on est un an d'accord
antibio qui peut décrédibiliser à tout
prix le bio dire que c'est trop cher que
si finalement c'est pas si bien et c'est
pour je ne sais quelle raison et faire
encore porter le chapeau aux
consommateurs non le bio c'est très bien
il ya moins de pesticides c'est pas
forcément beaucoup plus cher aujourd'hui
ça c'est totalement démocratisé nouvel
an juste les lions est ce que le fait
que le bio soit démocratisé se sont
démocratisés pose pas une question parce
que ça voudrait dire aussi que peut-être
les degré d'exigence ont été baissés
pour qu'on arrive à ce à deux buts mais
c'est toujours moins pire sera toujours
moins pire que la très très très grande
distribution par exemple de l'empreinte
carbone parce qu'on va chercher du bio à
l'autre bout du monde
moi je dis ça va moi je suis fois cette
année sa superbe duo la pâte dure à
l'est oui on le met dans un magasin bio
c'était moins pire aux voeux c'est ça
n'était pas du tout juste 10 me
rapidement qu'est ce que vous entendez
je pense qu'on commence à confondre un
peu tous sur le bio et on a l'impression
que manger bio c'est bien manger or là
on voit dans cet exemple on parle d'une
pizza bio mais ce que manger une pizza
bio c'est mieux que de manger un poisson
qui n'est pas forcément de buyo mais ça
reste du poisson donc attention à pas
croire que bio égale bonne alimentation
très vite et ouais non je voulais dire à
carreaux qu'elle est hyper naiz quand ça
a marché qui a progressé en cinq ans de
80% tu vas pas me faire croire que l'abe
seront toutes les marques bio sont
forcément sereine et sont forcément avec
des bons produits jeudi peut pas grandir
et on a posé la question des
téléspectateurs est ce que vous faites
confiance au magasin bio oui ou non et
vous nous dites non à 74%
visiblement nos téléspectateurs ne sont
pas dupes madame voilà ce que je voulais
dire